we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors blinkist is the app that helps
you become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman all right the news
continues pouring in
things have simmered down a little bit
from the
ins insurrectionist riotous coup attempt
by trump supporters that took place
on wednesday but a lot of crazy is
really going on i told you yesterday
that facebook and twitter had
temporarily suspended donald trump for
posting election dissing
disinformation and incitements to
violence we have now heard from mark
zuckerberg facebook will be blocking
donald trump
on all its platforms which includes
instagram
at least until the end of his presidency
uh mark zuckerberg made a post about
this
uh yesterday and you know i i don't
really
care about zuckerberg in the term in
terms of evaluating his morality and his
personal politics i know that
there's reason to be very upset as to
how facebook has sort of looked the
other way with a lot of the
completely ridiculous ways that the
trump campaign and the right have used
facebook to spread disinformation and so
on
uh this statement from mark zuckerberg
is what it is and zuckerberg wrote the
shocking events over the last 24 hours
clearly demonstrate that president
donald trump intends to use his
remaining time in office to undermine
the peaceful and lawful transition of
power
to his elected successor joe biden
and he goes on to say we believe the
risks of allowing the president to
continue to use our service during this
period are simply too great
therefore we are extending the block we
have placed on his facebook and
instagram accounts indefinitely
and for at least the next two weeks
until the peaceful transition of power
is complete so a
an indefinite ban on facebook and
instagram for donald trump and it's all
just
you know the the struggle with these um
incidents
is that on the one hand all of this
stuff should have happened long ago
trump's cabinet should have considered
the 25th amendment long ago
trump's cabinet should have resigned
long ago republicans should have
abandoned trump long ago
pence should have distanced from trump
long ago on
twitter and facebook all this stuff but
at this late stage
it's sort of like come on guys uh it
almost feels like a
virtue signal in some sense to me uh
in order to try to rehabilitate one's
image and one could be a person or
a company when it's too little too late
when trump is now
already weakened and humiliated with
just you know 12 days left until the
inauguration
so while these are obviously the correct
decisions it's hard to really
feel like wow it's so great everybody's
now
figuring it out we figured it out before
trump was even inaugurated and some of
us were called alarmists and of course
every one of our worst
fears uh came true so we'll continue to
follow this uh i believe it's quite
plausible trump will be permanently
banned
uh from um uh twitter as well
uh after he leaves office but
it is it's really anyone's guess at this
point
and one of the things i think it's it's
important to remember
i mentioned this yesterday let's not
allow
the uh retroactive rehabilitation
of the image of a lot of these people
that were along for the ride
99.9 percent of trump's term and now are
bailing
absolutely massive conflict
within trump's cabinet uh on wednesday
as the violent insurrection was
breaching the capital donald trump
denounced mike pence and said pence
didn't do it pence didn't do it he
didn't steal the election
for me and that tweet was ultimately
taken down
by twitter and it was one of the tweets
that led to donald trump's suspension on
twitter
donald trump's attorney general william
barr is now calling donald trump's
behavior
a betrayal of the presidency and also
said yesterday that trump's
orchestrating a mob to pressure congress
is inexcusable
now again the analysis is very similar
barr was trump's unmitigated unrepentant
henchman
for years barr deserves none of our
sympathy
barr is bailing as the ship is sinking
but it's still great to see him say this
former attorney general william barr is
reported by the associated press
says donald trump's conduct as a violent
mob of his supporters stormed the u.s
capitol
was a quote betrayal of his office and
supporters
barr said that orchestrating a mob to
pressure congress is inexcusable
the statement has been obtained by nbc
news and the associated press was
the first to report on it uh notable yes
do you tend to see a president denounce
their vice president
and an attorney general denounce the
president that selected them
no you don't and that is significant but
everything that's happening right now is
significant
much of what's happening right now is
unprecedented we are in dangerous
unprecedented times
at the same time bar's disgusting barr
deserves to never work again
uh and you will remember that uh bar
resigned last month
and uh was replaced by by another uh
loyalist and um it happened shortly
after william barr said there was no
widespread fraud that had any
impact on the the results of the
election so these are strange times
but let's not say william barr is a good
guy
um you know people like john bolton and
others who
after the fact say what was obviously
true all along
i don't see them as anything
approximating heroes i see them as
people who
for as long as it was comfortable for as
long as they could get away with it they
were happy
being in proximity to power and having
access to the president
and having that prestigious title and
then
when it starts to become a risk for
their
future their career future their
political future then they come out and
say something like this so is william
william barr is obviously right william
barr is completely right in saying
that what donald trump has done is a
betrayal it's seditious it's arguably
treasonous there's no question about it
um but the idea that there is anything
uh um morally admirable about what
william barr is doing
throw that in the trash forget about it
i want to elaborate a little bit on my
comments yesterday
about the republican party crumbling
under donald trump
and trump really losing everything for
the republican party
with a focus not on evaluating the
virtue or morality of any particular
individual republican
because as i told you they all deserve
uh the repercussions of sticking by
trump for 99.9
of the presidency but i think that we
are going to see
a six-month period into joe biden's
transition that will really be unlike
anything we've seen before i know donald
trump often says this is like nothing
we've seen before
this really is like nothing we've seen
before we have never had a situation
where
during a global hundred year pandemic we
have
a president made a one-term president
who refuses to accept that they actually
lost
incites dozens of bogus lawsuits
and a violent riotous insurrection that
leads to
a temporary delay in the counting of the
electoral votes
gets suspended from multiple social
media networks for
um essentially praising the violence
saying the pro-t understands why the
protesters did what they did this is
what you get when you steal an election
donald trump saying on twitter before
twitter deleted that
we have never had a situation like this
and so
we are seeing mitch mcconnell the
absolutely
horrible senate majority leader lose his
position as senate majority leader
likely uh to um be replaced by uh
democrat chuck schumer as democrats take
control
of the senate thanks to the two runoff
victories in georgia by rafael warnock
and john ossoff on tuesday night into
wednesday morning
and you also are going to see at the
same time that republicans lose control
of the senate
you see them very much on the defensive
having to either denounce or jump in
with or explain away
this riotous insurrection that took
place on wednesday
at a time when we so desperately need
leadership
at a time when the economy is as
precarious as it's ever been
we had i i wondered six days ago
will we get to 4 000 coronavirus deaths
a day well on wednesday we had 4 100.
as the violent insurrection was taking
place
and donald trump was getting banned from
twitter and facebook as all that was
going on
we passed for the first time 4 000
coronavirus dead in one day in fact the
number i believe was was 4 100.
so what is going to be the role of the
republican party in the next two years
what is going to be their role as uh
uh we we hopefully start to see
vaccination help
tamp down the pandemic in a more
permanent way
are they going to do what we've
suspected for a long time
which is sort of kind of pretending they
were never really with trump even if
they were and going back to we can't
afford this and what about the dead and
we need to be
uh constitutional conservatives and
financial conservatives
what exactly is going to be their uh
what what exactly is going to be their
approach
and on in a very practical sense joe
biden said earlier this week
two thousand dollar stimulus checks are
riding on the georgia elections
democrats got the two georgia elections
are we getting two thousand dollar
stimulus checks now
uh democrats have control will will have
control of the house
senate and white house and they've been
talking about two thousand dollar
stimulus checks democrats in the house
and senate have said they're okay with
two thousand dollar stimulus checks
so is that going to happen uh are we
going to see
to what degree and i i am not yet
taking a position i want to think about
it more to what degree
is a biden administration potentially
with attorney general merrick garland
and control of the house and senate to
investigate whatever the hell they want
to what degree are the trump crime
families wrongdoings
going to be investigated um there
are a lot of compelling arguments to be
made one way or another about the
investigation of former former president
in the united states but
what do that these next two years look
like do republicans
manage to become uh acute
obstructionists
do they sort of act like normal people
for a little bit is it conceivable and i
know this is so it's almost naive and
cliche
to say but do a few reasonable
reasonable republicans
that saw the error of trump trump's ways
like
you know the perpetually disappointed
susan collins and
mitt romney who voted to to convict on
one
of the two articles of impeachment do
they
join democrats in the senate so that
it's
not 50 50 if joe manchin is okay
with a tiebreaker by kamala harris but
maybe it's 52-48 on some of these key
issues
uh would susan collins and mitt romney
go for
some some you know green energy
infrastructure deal with some teeth
to it i don't know i don't know the
answers but what we do know
is that donald trump has lost everything
for the republican party
losing them the house in 2018 losing
them the senate and the white house in
2020.
the republican party in a sense is
crumbling but we know from history
is very resilient and has voters who are
very willing
to say oh trump's gone we're back to we
care about the debt and deficit
and blocking abortion again and you know
religious freedom or whatever we know
they're eager to get back to that and so
the next two years are a real question
mark i think
joe biden's first hundred days will tell
us a lot about how that's going to go
let me know what you expect i'm on
twitter at deepakman the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and other
things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
8 bucks a month and you get the entire
library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
welcome back to the show it has been a
huge huge
political week so many things have taken
place and i know people are eager to
uh chat and tell me what they're
thinking of and what's going on and
let's do it via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord uh you can also join the
discussion happening on discord i think
close to
i think we've got close to 10 000 people
on our discord which is
a perfect number let's first go
to uh let's go to jill
from burbank jill from burbank you're on
the air
what is going on
hi david good morning to you oh it's
morning over here
how are you pretty good how about
yourself
uh doing well how's it it's raining in
burbank
um so i was gonna ask you in regards to
the policy
what do you wanna see um
you know now that democrats have the
senate and the house
yeah and the presidency yes uh what
policies do you want to see i really
want to see
progressive um you know
the green new new deal like on the table
the beta what do you um
i mean listen jill it's such a long list
so first on day one
you know day one could mean the first
couple of weeks uh joe biden needs to do
everything he promised to do via
executive order that he can do
and reversing a lot of the things that
donald trump did i think using the
defense production act to scale up
vaccine
production is something i would i would
be very interested in
very quickly uh he and democrats in the
house and senate
should be able to should be able to get
a bigger stimulus done
uh having mitch mcconnell um out of
power is just
uh such a fantastic thing
um and then i want biden to get started
on the big things let's get started on
the public option let's get started on
the energy uh and climate proposal that
he did which is not the green new deal
but takes a lot from the green new deal
um let's do minimum wage i mean
it's such a long list it's all possible
now but now is when the work begins and
that's the thing
there's i saw a lot of people gloating
this is just the beginning
this is we we now have to actually get
something done
and it's not going to be as easy as many
think but the list is very long and it's
exactly the type of thing we should be
thinking of
right what what do you think
the student loan is gonna get passed uh
at all like uh student loan forgiveness
he said
you know i'm skeptical i'm skeptical
that it's going to get passed
and um that that one i would love to see
something done on student loans it's a
huge priority and be very economically
stimulative
to redirect money away from being
interest paid to banks
to money people can spend at local
businesses but i i am
i have a skepticism that that gets done
in the next two years and
that i feel like that's the problem with
you know
biden and you know the difference
between trump and biden trump
you know says something he just goes and
writes whatever
and you know it's it's an executive
order yeah but that's not that's let's
not give trump too much credit
trump did nothing on health insurance
trump promised health insurance
he yeah it's not he's yeah i hate him
but
he you know he does that i i wish
you know that no but i think the point
is trump has done
nothing on many of the it's not just
that trump is odd he does bad things but
he does them
most of the stuff he promised he just
didn't even he just didn't even come
close to doing he just didn't do
anything on
i i totally agree with that yeah
you know just but like for example for
toilet and stuff he just when
it does nothing really what he wrote but
he
goes ahead and writes a writes an
executive order
but anyways in regards to the mega
people that's the last question
what's the best way to you know change
their heart
i mean i from my experience i think
showing
how we used to be you know how we used
to talk
as a family friend um is the best way
but what do you think is the best way to
do it i don't think
that there is any what i call retail
strategy
arguing with individual trumpists
one-on-one
it's there's no way there's no way we
need
a wholesale strategy which includes
cultural change
educational change and it's a it's at
least
a decade process unfortunately and i
know a lot of people want
just like what's the trick to convince
these three maggot people i know to
change their minds
it the problem is just way it's way
bigger than that unfortunately
well thank you so much uh david
do do exactly what you're doing and we
love you
thank you all right jill from burbank
very much appreciate the call
we are taking calls uh via discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go next to
ben in rural or oregon or
rural oregon as some people would say
ben are you there
ben are you there you've gotta unmute
all right no ben that's too bad let's go
instead to matt
in rural new york we'll just keep it
rural what's going on matt
hey david um big fan of the show um
one of my super chats didn't get
addressed yesterday which is fine
you know it's it's hard to keep up on
all those yeah they were they were
it was explosive with super chop um so
one thing that i just wanted to state as
being a former election worker is
one of the questions you had which is is
there
a section for a write-off in a runoff
election
um and there's not an official space for
that so for a write-in yeah yeah right
so let me give the back story on that it
could spoil the ballot
right so there was a question yesterday
about
uh whether uh there could be candidates
could you have a runoff where no one
gets 50
and by definition in the runoff there's
no right in there's no third party it's
the two candidates
that qualified for the runoff it's one
or the other and so it's mathematically
impossible
to have uh both under 50 thanks for
clarifying that matt
correct yeah um so i guess my main
question was
it's about the democratic party and its
outreach
so i know that you had those contacts in
georgia that have been campaigning
furiously for both campaigns
yeah but you know it's not a secret that
the democratic party is
really awful at outreach and i think
that was pretty evident in the latino
vote in florida
yes so obviously you know the pandemic
has changed pretty much all traditional
methods of outreach
and i my question was what do you think
the democratic party could do
to improve outreach not only to these
minority communities in these key
battleground states but to young voters
as well
well i i i think it's a good question
but i also want to push back a little in
the sense that
joe biden managed to win while running a
pandemic safe campaign
while trump did everything you would do
as if there was no pandemic going on so
as terrible as democrats are they
maintained control of the house
they won the senate and they made trump
a one-term president
all while doing it safe from the
standpoint of a pandemic so i
actually am more encouraged by
democratic organizing in 2020
because it's been so disastrous in the
past i think they've done better
with with online um so i think obviously
more can be done i think the florida
example is a very good one where
they were directly fighting against
these just blanket
communism socialism fears and i don't
think that the democratic party
particularly with the latino vote
has really figured out how to fight that
yet so there's a huge uphill battle
you're completely right
but i mean the i don't want the results
haven't been perfect democrats lost
seats in the house while maintaining
control
and there were senate races that could
have been won which they didn't which
made it come down to georgia
but when you win everything i mean yes
trump is terrible and trump damaged the
republican party
but you can't say they're absolutely
disastrous when they won everything
yeah i i guess i meant more in a
limited context and you know georgia was
very encouraging
yeah and for those house elections
one of the districts near me is the uh
the race that's within 12 votes and that
hasn't been called yet
right uh with claudia tenney that's
that's the race that trump's just
going after and saying it's corrupt and
i think he's
campaigned for her a few times here in
upstate new york
so it's just really discouraging to see
this but georgia
you know it's it's very encouraging
from the senate standpoint so absolutely
thank you
georgia thanks matt i appreciate it very
very much
um we are taking calls via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord let's talk to a few other people
at least
uh why don't we go uh to let's go to ben
from boston
ben from boston you're on the air oh
hey um
did you just call me like a minute ago i
just clicked on
the chat ben i can i can barely hear you
uh
you're gonna have to get much closer to
your microphone or something and i i
called on you now i don't know i it
sounded like you were asking if i
previously called on you
i called on you now there was a
different ben i tried calling on before
but it wasn't you
thank you that makes a lot more sense
now hey um
is this better it's a little better yeah
go ahead okay thank you
um so i was just wondering your take on
kind of
for going forward what what should the
mainstream media
kind of do to um kind of
quell some of this division that i see
my my dad was actually a
sports journalist for many many years in
the past
and he's always told me about that a lot
of this partisanship kind of started
uh when the if you've heard of this like
um
the fairness doctrine the fcc a fairness
doctrine that
basically mandated that there had to be
uh both sides of you know both sides of
an argument to be presented there was
sort of limited number of channels
and they wanted that you know certain
channels to have you know
maybe a left leaning perspective
and a right leaning just have air time
on on both sides
and i think reagan ended that uh
practice
um and my dad always tells me that you
know he thinks that a lot of this kind
of
division um and um polarization in the
news
has started around around then
um so i was just wondering um but your
take on that and
and and perhaps also you know i wondered
if
a lot of people don't understand the
difference between let's say like news
and opinion yes and maybe there should
be better
um regulation i know regulation
so regulation is stuff let me that's
that's a lot so let me let me deal with
that because that's a lot of stuff
um the people the second part is
immediate lack of media literacy
i've addressed that before we need to be
teaching media literacy
starting you know two to 11 year olds
even younger being able to identify the
difference between
content and advertising which really
young kids can't do which is why
advertising to children is so pernicious
the difference between news and opinion
that's a we have a huge media literacy
issue in the country but the first issue
is very interesting
i think at this point there are people
who say we need a new fairness doctrine
at this point i believe that practically
speaking
because so much of the information
people are getting is on the internet
uh it seems to me that a new fairness
doctrine would be a pyrrhic victory
in the sense that you might through huge
amounts of struggle and chaos
get something done and it would be of
minimal value
because the media landscape has just
changed dramatically it's not about
limited airwaves that have to be divided
fairly in a certain way
it's a totally different situation with
people getting news from the internet so
i don't think that the regulatory
approach in terms of a new fairness
doctrine is the right approach
i think it's a we need a cultural
educational realignment
that teaches people to
be more savvy when it comes to the
information that that they consume i
feel strongly that that's the right
approach and that a new fairness
doctrine would not really be what we
need
my pleasure great to hear from you uh
let's take a very quick break if you're
holding
don't hang up because we're going right
back to the phones momentarily
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing you get access to the world-famous
bonus show
every single day just for members as
well as commercial free
audio and video feeds of the show
day in and day out you can sign up for
membership
very very quickly at joinpacman.com
that's join
p a k m dot if the normal prices
strike you as high by all means use the
coupon code
vote soon 18 all one word all lower case
become a member today
welcome back to the david pakman show
let's go back to the phone lines uh i
guess they're really more like internet
tubes via discord
davidpakman.com slash
discord is the place let's talk to
tim from new york tim from new york
you're on the air
from new york please unmute yourself and
you'll be able to talk to me
and last chance for tim from
new york no tim from new york let's go
instead to tyler
from australia tyler from australia
you were on the air what's going on
there hi david how you doing
good how are you i'm doing great
um earlier today on twitter i saw a
picture of
a u.s flat with 52 stars and
now that the dems have the senate the
house and the presidency
i was wondering what your opinion is or
if you think it's possible that we can
have maybe
one or two more states uh
given statehood it would be absolutely
fantastic
i am very significantly supportive of it
i think
dc as a democratic state is obvious
because
it's so overwhelmingly democratic i
actually think it's a little less clear
in in terms of puerto rico because there
is actually a
a a more conservative contingent there
and
if puerto rico were to become a state i
think you would see republicans
pour in resources to try to get a
senator there
um so i think that um it on balance dc
plus puerto rico is absolutely good for
democrats i think
if you're assuming it would be all uh
democrats
you you you may be wrong but i would be
hugely supportive of that and i would
love to see democrats
in control of the house senate and the
white house take that up and look at
making that a reality
yeah i was pretty much certain that the
dc area would
go heavily towards the democrats but
right i was a bit more worried about the
puerto rico area because
it's like a bit more of that latina void
and
yeah but remember the latino vote the
latino vote is very left other than
cuban americans but
that can still mean you have 35 percent
38 41 that would still be i don't know
exactly what the numbers are in puerto
rico
you still end up with some republican
members of congress and maybe even
a senator depending on who chooses to
vote with those numbers it's just less
overwhelming in puerto rico
yeah right so it could even bounce out
with just like a one for one
i don't think it would i think i think
it would lean blue but it's just not
there's some people who are like this
it'll be all democrats and i think that
that's probably not true
yeah all right well thank you very much
all right my pleasure great to uh great
to hear from you
let's go next to mackenzie
mackenzie you were on the air
mackenzie i heard you just for a second
there you're on the air
oh no david oh no david you caught me
you caught me in some dough i'm sorry
you're literally me are you canadian yes
sir oh you are
uh um yeah you're making bagels didn't
switch myself to just listening so sorry
you're literally making bagels right now
you betcha yeah
that is unbelievable and so is that you
boil and then you bake
i boil yes and then i bake that's
incredible and what flavors are you uh
making
uh we got everything going on right now
black sesame
uh sesame and some some onion and garlic
is this a is this a is your job to make
bagels or you just do this
like as a for home yeah yeah that's my
job i'm a baker
oh okay that's fantastic yeah i always
listen while i work it's the best and uh
didn't i
this cupboard and flour couldn't switch
to just listening
i'm this is fascinating what part of
canada are you in
uh right in the middle it's not toronto
not vancouver
okay all right fair enough and you can
get a good you can get a good game
vagina what's that you can get a good
bagel in that part of canada
uh since i moved back from australia
yeah i love it i love it all right
now thanks for the chess games by the
way i had you on a couple malty days we
had a couple good ones
oh beautiful who won uh you took the
last two and
and i didn't go for the rematch okay
that's fair that's fair all right listen
um bagels we i love bit i ca i'm glad i
stumbled across this because i love
bagels
i'll have something more useful for you
next time okay thank you very much
there's cheers brother
mackenzie the baker who didn't even want
to talk to me
sort of forced him into it crazy
uh all right let's speak next
to ivan from california ivan from
california you're on the air
david can you hear me yes i can oh
excellent
oh wow david deepak pakman um okay
so um yeah something i've been thinking
about lately
is um to what point could we
call the republican party fascist or
like crypto fascist or is that even like
productive
because i think it's not productive i
think i think i've been using more the
term here's the way i i've been seeing
it because sometimes when you
when you over label you you just damage
yourself
trump is authoritarian and he has
fascistic tendencies
and i think he would love to be a
dictator if he could get away with it
but saying
this is a fascist administration trump's
desires are fascistic
uh i i don't know that we get that much
from saying
this is fascism and i think it sort of
uh
discounts real fascism that we've seen
in practice i think trump has fascistic
delusions
i see i see okay um
thank you um can i ask you a little
quickie sure yeah go ahead
so i'm sure you're familiar with jorge
luis borges of course
of course um any other great argentine
writers i should
look into yeah um you know actually let
me let's see
one i don't know if you've read let me
remember which one
the uh which which uh okay so so
certainly um julio cortazar
is fantastic and he wrote the novel
um rashwella which is hopscotch
translated in english and a bunch of
short stories that are really good i
would dig into some of that
oh lovely thank you so much peace and
love
all right peace and love peace and love
thank you so much great to hear from you
a lot of references a lot of memetic
references in that call for sure
let's go next to
uh where did we want to go a lot of
people just listening which is totally
fine
i'm not gonna force you in let's go to
um let's go to
roland from vienna
roland from vienna
roland from vienna david hello
how are you david great great great
listen congrats on the
georgia runoff yes
i'm i'm a 40 year old white male from
the middle of europe
okay is it weird to say that stacy
abrams is my new hero
no no i mean what she's been able to do
is is incredible
it's you know earlier we had that call
about democrats failing on organizing
stacey abram stacey abrams should be
explaining to
national democrats how to organize quite
frankly
yeah that's in fact the only downside
i'm seeing
is uh uh it's all good for chuck schumer
to be in the driving seat now but uh why
did nancy pelosi have to stay there
right well listen i mean i think um the
the truth is that what really matters is
sort of like the average
uh placement on the political spectrum
of the house and senate
and the senate has been pulled a little
to the left
with the addition of ossoff and warnock
and
or significantly to the left and the
house even though democrats lost seats
some of the people who won
are more left so i think i think it's
okay i think there's a realistic chance
to get some important things done here
well you'll get there you'll get there
listen dave thanks a lot for what you're
doing to be honest i
i started watching you about a year ago
yes and i started watching for the
political commentary
and then i kept watching for the comedy
it is
especially your live streams i just it's
hilarious so much fun
uh with the callers also and uh i think
it's time for a spin-off show
really and what will your spin-off be
like you're saying a spin-off comedy
show
yeah yeah you have the uh um yeah maybe
some viewer generated contact i know you
have
and i'm also a big fan of your your uh
one of your
uh regular call-ins to the voicemail the
eggman
yes of course eggman is is a fantastic
caller
roland i like that idea we'll take that
under advisement maybe
a scripted comedy my middle name my
middle name is eggbert so it's gonna be
eggbert and the eggman
i'm gonna connect with that guy and
we'll make it happen for you david
let's do it all right yes eggman and egg
bert let's put everybody together
have a good one okay thanks there's a
roland from vienna
very very excited uh to do a
a collab with the eggman let's go next
to rashad from brooklyn rashad from
brooklyn you're on the air
rashad from brooklyn please unmute
and you will be able to talk to me
and yes
am i coming through clear yes you are
perfectly clear pristine
beautiful you know it's a second caller
from new york
actually yeah
what can i do for you rashad
so i think stacey abram is
i mean i guess in reference to the
previous caller
stacey abram has been a hero for the
the georgia senate erect election and
even the presidency
and i think she showed that there
probably are more
swing states if democrats are willing to
work
right and i was wondering and yeah and i
was wondering if you thought there were
like any other potential swing states
that if democrats put just
just enough resources into that we would
be able to maybe possibly
flip them blue well north carolina is a
state that is sometimes blue
that could be much more reliably blue
with more democratic effort
um but then texas is the the sort of
obvious big one because the reward is
just so big and
we thought it would be closer than it
ultimately ended up being
i never thought that democrat that joe
biden would win texas
but there was the idea that it would be
close and it was sort of close but not
as close as maybe we would have wanted i
think
texas particularly with a lot of
liberals moving to the austin area
um i i think there's major potential and
the reward
for making texas at least sometimes blue
would be absolutely devastating to uh
the republican party at the national
level
yeah i mean if you like can you imagine
if democrats actually
find a way to make texas a swing state
like
republicans would never almost never win
an election
i mean yes it's it's really not far from
being a swing state
it's it's close to being a swing state
and i think the lesson from stacey
abrams should be
let's put four years into texas starting
now so that it can be a swing state by
2024
yeah that sounds like a great idea dave
yeah
well i guess that's about it thank you
david all right thank you
do you know any particularly good
argentinian restaurants here in new york
yes uh yes go to it's called
el gauchito and it is in the corona
elmhurst area of queens excellent
excellent argentinian restaurant i don't
know what's going on from the standpoint
of the virus right now and and dining
there
but a fantastic argentinian restaurant
in queens
thank you david i appreciate it my
pleasure all right there is rashad
from brooklyn very very exciting
and uh you never know what you're going
to get
when you show up at an argentinian
restaurant
let's go to chris from colorado
chris from colorado you're on the air
chris hello you are so low you sound
like you're a hundred feet from the
phone chris
whoa chris are you there
yeah man i don't know what people are
doing when it sounds that like i really
i can't in that like do i ever sound
that way on the phone i don't know
let's go to adam from dc adam from dc
hey there david how are you doing good
how are you pretty good
um i'm wondering what realistically now
that the
democrats have a tenuous lead in the
senate uh can get done
i don't think dc statehood or puerto
rican statehood is on the table but
maybe some smaller stuff what would you
like to see done
uh another stimulus bill yep i think
that gets done
climate change controls um
stuff of that nature yeah i think that
uh i mean listen
some of the climate stuff can be done by
executive order because uh joe biden
trump damaged a lot of climate stuff by
reducing regulations via executive order
joe biden can put them right back in
now that's small potatoes we want more
and i'm being very clear we want more we
want a big legislative deal
i think the dream would be a major
infrastructure
green energy sustainable business deal
like a big
really big big deal but in the immediate
joe biden can
can undo some of trump's economic damage
regulatory
uh uh ease uh loosening of regulatory uh
climate-related regulations via
executive order
i think the stimulus gets done um i
think the bigger questions are
you know do we do we really get a good
shot at a public option
um etc uh i think that and it remains to
be seen
you really think that the public option
is on the table i mean it can't
replace well it's biden's it's
it's on the table in the sense that it's
what biden ran on and until he proves
until he shows me he doesn't actually
want to try it
i believe he will at some point try to
do it and then whether it can get done
is the question
yeah that's kind of what i was uh
alluding to
i know that we don't have a
filibuster-proof majority so yeah
people can just simply kill it they can
the question would be at what political
cost if it's very popular and it is
uh the question would be what at what
political cost and i think
it's great to be thinking ahead about
this but let's see how the next two
weeks go
and let's see how biden's first two
weeks of executive orders go and then
let's start building the legislative
agenda
sounds good david uh thanks for taking
my call you have a great day sir
my absolute pleasure thank you so much
that is going to do it for calls today
we will take calls again and i hope you
will join me
for a whole new week of shows but we'll
be back with more right after this quick
break
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous at this point
and the daily commercial free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
slash david pakman show this is audience
supported media
we depend on the support of our viewers
and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us on tv
or even listen on the radio patreon.com
david pakman show
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
okay let's get into our first audience
questions for 2021 a very good ones ones
i'm looking forward to
answering first is david do you think we
really could be approaching a secession
civil war scenario after january
20th i think that the answer is no now
if you step back and say well i'm going
to just focus on are there secessionist
movements
and is there a group that would love to
use militia organization and militia
power
to separate or to go against what is
going to be a biden-run federal
government yeah there's there's no
shortage of that but
the country has changed dramatically
from the times of the civil war
in the civil war you had two very
clearly defined
factions they were geographically
much more homogeneous than what we have
now where you have even in red states
the cities are often blue even in blue
states the rural areas
are often red right and now it's a very
urban rural
situation within states in the civil war
it was different each side had a
a military to back it up in a more
sort of equal way and so right now a lot
of different things
have changed first there's this sort of
geographical complexity
uh it's not clear like which states
would be part of which side
uh urban rural within states is the sort
of circumstance number two financial
red states are not viable without blue
states and we've talked a lot about when
you look at
whether states pay in more or get more
back
from the federal government the blue
states overwhelmingly pay in more
whereas the red states are more likely
to be leechers and receive
more from the federal government and
absent that
um a lot of those red states would not
even be financially
viable and my my guess would be is if
you see
some of these groups militias etc
escalate
into bombings shootings etc
you would see the tide turn with
police and national guard forces likely
putting them down
without even getting to some kind of a
more federal
response however i mean like let's think
ahead
if you imagine these red states somehow
come together and they say we're going
to use our combine our state national
guards
i'm speaking so hypothetically um
the the reddest states all together have
national guard forces of about 200
000 troops and the federal government
is about a million and a half troops and
they have all the real firepower
and so from a purely logistical
perspective
i'm not saying that right-wing militias
can't cause chaos oh they absolutely can
they can cause chaos they can cause
death they can do horrible horrible
things
but the circumstances are simply not
uh ones that would lend themselves to a
true civil war and if the federal
army if the army were to be used by the
federal level
um to suppress this
you know homegrown militias are not
going to be a match for the u.s
military for better or worse we can talk
about military industrial complex we can
talk about all of these other things
um but i actually think the more
interesting topic is
are there enough just people willing and
interested in that
i know that you know you half the
country or a third for 35
of the country didn't vote of the people
that voted for trump
um half believe that trump is ultimately
going to
be sworn in some of those when trump is
not sworn in might be really really
angry
and some subset of those might want to
secede
and some subset of those might be
willing to actually go and fight for
that in some way
the point is i don't think there's
enough people actually interested in
that that that you're really going to
see any significant movement along those
lines
and i've talked before we have an
economic situation
that is designed to prevent people from
organizing in that way and
this is for better or worse i've talked
about how cheap stuff from china
combined with easy access to credit
um credit cards and personal credit
keeps people
relatively comfortable enough doesn't
mean that there's no poverty doesn't
mean that there's no hunger
but even people who otherwise might not
like without credit and cheap stuff from
china there would be lots of people who
on a day-to-day
uh um live far worse far less
comfortably than they do
so a lot of people are just going to say
do it you know i kind of would rather
just hang out and
you know watch sports not do whatever it
is this these secessionists want me to
do
combined with the fact that due to
stagnant wages and the precarious
financial situation of many people
a lot of people you know oh let's go
let's go uh wage a civil war and try to
secede
i'll be gone for two weeks wait a second
then i lose health care and lose my
income and then if we don't succeed
when i get back what do i have i lose my
house my car gets repossessed or
whatever so
that is to some degree by design in the
system that we have and i've spoken
about that before so
i do not expect that that is going to
lead to
anything even approximating the real
threat of what we might recognize as a
civil war david i like the idea
of single payer but how do you deal with
increased demand for medical services if
single payer passes
if everything is free at the point of
care
people are going to start going to
doctors for all sorts of procedures how
do we deal with that
this is sort of a ruse okay and i like
the
i love the opportunity to talk about
this because there's so many different
things to consider
first of all let's apply the sniff test
to it
if you're talking about unnecessary
medical procedures
where people would get them for kicks if
it was free
what actually falls under that umbrella
that has no preventive benefit what what
i mean by that is
in every single payer proposal i've seen
um
unnecessary cosmetic plastic surgery
that's not medically necessary it's not
reconstructive in some way for example
wouldn't be covered by single-payer you
you would still have to say if i want
breast implants if i want a nose job
absence some trauma or you know a
mastectomy or other situations
it's not covered i've got to pay for
that out of pocket okay so once you take
cosmetic plastic surgery
off the table what what what somebody
who people are going to get hip
replacements just for kicks even though
they don't really need them
people are going to get um you know
dental cleanings which redu dental
cleanings reduce the cost of care
by preventing cavities as an example and
preventing gum issues so
when you really get down to it you could
see
a decrease in demand for some of the
more resource
intensive healthcare preventive care
reduces the number of er visits for
heart attacks and strokes
and abscesses that could have been
treated early on
and reduces uh demand for icu and other
acute services because
you're catching medical issues earlier
you're addressing them earlier
and you prevent some of that really
expensive specialized care so number one
when you really think about it the
things people are mostly not doing
because of financial obstacles aren't
things
people do for fun and this gets to the
most important point
and really the fundamental reason why a
for-profit health care system doesn't
make sense
demand for most medical services is
completely inelastic okay let's talk
this through and i hope i can do this
clearly going back to my
uh micro economic days if you take a
good
like for example i don't know uh
sharpies as an example where there's
lots of
substitutes for sharpies and
uh sharpies are an item where you might
prefer the sharpie to a pen
but you might not but there's some okay
etc
if sharpies are a penny each demand
explodes
tons of people if the sharpie goes to a
penny
i'll buy a ton of sharpies and just use
them maybe instead of a pen or some
other marker
if the sharpie goes to a thousand
dollars demand goes to almost zero very
few people like sharpies enough to pay a
grand each and they'll switch to
something else you'll go to a pencil
you'll go to you know whatever if
there's no obvious alternatives you'll
you'll you'll get uh chalk i don't know
okay so that's there's elasticity there
significant elasticity
when you take if you uh fall down and
you need a hip replacement
whether the hip replacement costs a
million dollars
or a hundred thousand dollars or twenty
five thousand dollars or ten thousand
dollars or a thousand dollars
my demand for a hip replacement is
absolute
if i need a hip replacement um and it's
essentially zero
if i don't need a hip replacement no
matter how cheap you make hip
replacements
no matter how much access you give me to
hip replacements with single payer
and of course it ignores that a doctor
wouldn't recommend one if there's no
reason to do it
my demand for a hip replacement is zero
so this is not a normal market
good and so the um
reality is you know consider
appendectomy i have
i had an appendectomy a year and a few
months ago
up until the day on which my uh appendix
started swelling and requiring to come
out
my demand for appendectomy services was
zero regardless of the cost i wouldn't
even take a free appendectomy i wouldn't
even
take money to get an appendectomy
suddenly i need one
and my demand is absolute okay so this
is the point the the increase
that people are are uh expecting um
is simply not going to be there from the
standpoint of people getting
services they don't need most of the
services people would avail themselves
of
if money were not an object are going to
be preventive services that actually
reduce acute disease in the long run
and reduce costs so it's essentially a
farce that's the reality
um and i one last thing i know some
people will say but david when
access to medicaid is increased
emergency room visits go
up very very different medicaid is not
medicare medicaid is primarily for poor
or disabled folks
and in particular it's folks who have a
backlog of more serious chronic issues
than the average
population and it is not representative
of what would happen
a bigger picture uh you have
there's very many specific issues with
that that make it not analogous to what
you would see bigger picture all right
so let me know if i'm missing anything
but that's
my general take on that hey david joe
biden keeps talking about compromising
with republicans and working across the
aisle
is biden nuts for thinking this
republican party will compromise with
him
well this this requires some speculation
about what biden actually thinks and
believes
what i mean by that is i don't know that
joe biden really thinks this republican
party is going to work with him and in
fact
i doubt he thinks that i believe joe
biden is talking about
reaching across the aisle and getting
republicans to compromise
because he's trying to be a unifying
figure who at least appears willing to
reach out to republican
voters it makes him look presidential it
appeals to more than just the democratic
party
and it in a way puts pressure on
republicans
many are friends with biden remember
biden has a lot of republican friends
to try to rise above partisanship but
my belief is biden knows especially
because they've been clear
republicans will be obstructionist
buffoons
for the next at least two years likely
for
they will try to get in the way of any
accomplishment that the democratic party
tries to do and so i don't believe joe
biden's
rhetoric about bipartisanship and
compromise
will go anywhere i think with this
republican party the only
the only way to get them to work with
biden would be to make such
significant concessions that these
legislative victories would end up being
pyrrhic victories in other words
victories in which you you you do you
are
so much damage is inflicted upon you
that you start to wonder is it really
even a victory
in the net so um i think you know if i
believed biden
naively believed mitch mcconnell is
going to help him get
the tax reform done that he wants and
the public option of course no
that would be insanely naive of joe
biden but i don't think he believes that
i
believe it's mostly posturing i believe
joe biden knows because republicans have
made it clear
they will obstruct absolutely everything
that they can
and i'm not particularly optimistic that
republicans are going to participate in
anything
over the next four years so what can joe
biden get done
without republicans what can joe biden
get done
with executive orders it remains to be
seen and
we'll be here for the ride we've got a
great bonus show for you today make sure
you're signed up for a
membership at joinpakman.com we have a
new coupon code
better21 the meaning should be obvious
we want to have a better
2021 than 2020 better 21 you can sign up
now and be listening or watching today's
bonus show
within 60 seconds i promise you join
pacman.com coupon code better21
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman